conservative icon rush limbaugh was laid
to rest this wednesday after losing his
battle with lung cancer
it's coincidental but fitting that he
was buried this week during cpac a time
when conservatives come together
and celebrate and lay the groundwork for
the future of the republican party
rush has a special place in cpac lore he
gave a rousing speech there in 2009 as
president obama had just taken office
and the democrats had control of the
house and senate the gop
felt like it was reeling and rudderless
and then rush spoke and electrified the
party
we want the country to succeed and for
the country to succeed
its people its individuals must succeed
everyone among us must be pursuing
his ambition or her desire whatever with
excellence
trying to be the best they could be not
told as they are told by the democrat
party
we want every american to be the best
he or she chooses to be
we recognize we recognize that we are
all
individuals we love and revere our
founding documents the constitution and
the declaration of independence he
inspired conservatives to band together
and fight for their principles and he
inspired a generation of new
conservatives
with that speech i would know because i
was there it was my first cpac
but now russia's gone and it feels a lot
like 2009
again but a new generation of
conservatives are here to pick up his
torch
and carry on his legacy one of those
conservatives is madison cawthorne a
newly elected republican congressman
from north carolina
who gave his first speech at cpac
earlier today madison thank you for
joining us tonight
is this your first cpac or your first
speech at cpac
oh this is my first time actually coming
to see people right now i don't even
feel
i'm telling i don't not feel like i am
worthy of being compared to the great
rush limbaugh at all i'm just like you
katie he was an incredible mentor to me
myself yeah so this would have been my
11th cpac
so i'm very proud of that i learned a
lot being a young conservative there but
let's talk about you you're new in
congress
what are you learning there today and
how's the energy
who's there what's going on
well i'll tell you we're getting lots
done in congress katie uh we've actually
successfully renamed a post office
uh that's about it uh lots of progress
it is so
it is so dysfunctional in washington dc
and this is such a time when americans
actually need leadership
uh they need their representatives to be
working for them not playing politics
uh and that's all we're seeing is going
on and with nancy pelosi because why do
they even need congress when they can
just rule through executive order
so when it comes to the future of the
republican party you're obviously one of
the youngest if not the youngest
member of congress when it comes to
being a happy warrior what do you
what do you want to do what do you think
that conservatives have to do
to get back in the winning column to
take back the house maybe in 2022 you
know you can be
against the left but you also have to
provide a number of policy positions and
things for people to be hopeful for
exactly you know i think it's going back
to our founding principles and this is
not where
i believe the republican party has
veered off its course
in decades before when we actually just
started getting really involved in
social issues
uh when i think of the republican party
the the conservative movement it's all
about limited government
and that means that we are truly focused
on making sure that we're going to
defend our liberties we're going to make
sure we have a great moral foundation to
stand upon
and we're going to use all of that to
create an incredible economy and an
incredible country
that requires very little governance
because it's a moral people and they can
govern themselves so i think taking that
message to a new generation
that's been deceived by this outrage
culture that's been told that
conservatives are are racist or are
bigoted that can't be further from the
truth we are the big tent party but are
also
the party that welcomes diversity of
thought we want to have a debate with
you we don't want to cancel you
so you brought up the idea of people
governing themselves and that's
certainly a bedrock a conservative
principle but in your speech today you
talk specifically about
personal responsibility being
responsible for your own actions and
being capable of doing that in order to
move yourself forward so that everybody
can live their own lives and live
live out the way that they want to so
how do you get that message back into
your generation when a lot of us been
taught that
you know personal responsibility is not
really something you have to
take on board oh you're absolutely right
the
the way that we do this is by packaging
the message of
personal responsibility in a way that
makes sense uh and it's one that you
know
it encourages people and inspires people
to rise up to be a conservative
uh this should be the highest standard
in all of society not just a low bar
saying oh well if you believe in liberty
you can you can join our party no
if you want to be a millionaire you can
be in our party if you want to
live the most successful life you
possibly can you want to lead a ministry
if you want to run a non-profit
come to our party we're going to have
deregulation we're going to allow you to
live your life on your own terms
get rid of capital gains taxes get rid
of taxes across again
a federal income tax across the board so
that you have more of your own money in
your pocket this is things that
everybody can understand
and katie i think the really bedrock
principle we need to get back to
is dining room politics all politics are
local
if we are speaking to those young
families who are sitting around their
dinner table
and affecting change in the areas that
actually matter to them
then that's going to that's going to
bring the the new next generation back
to our party
so when it comes to you know bringing
we're a big it's a republican party as a
big ten party it's certainly expanded
under president trump when it comes to
just again
taking back the narrative when it comes
to the left saying that it's a party of
white supremacists and and bigots and
it's not a big tent party
how do you not just make statements but
get people to
change their votes and their party
affiliation
well you know what i think it's meeting
them where they are uh you know if you
sit
in bubbles that are completely
conservative your entire life uh you're
probably never gonna get to effect
change uh with a moderate or with a
liberal
uh but you know i think if people are
willing to have conversations again
instead of canceling your neighbor
communicate with them
and you know go have conversations with
people who disagree with you and we have
the common sense policies that actually
make sense
uh so instead of just going for the
jugular attacking people on personal
levels
if we were to actually get people to
come together and have a conversation i
think we would see
hoards of people come to the republican
party but unfortunately that's the exact
opposite of what the democrats want to
do you saw
the two of my colleagues authored a
letter trying to cancel this entire news
station
lots of letters from democrats uh and
censorship that's for sure so madison
cawthorn thank you for joining us on
your voyage journey to cpac have a great
time
it's it's very fun you'll be addicted
now i guarantee there'll be more of them
in your future thank you thank you